bajo amenazas y con disparos al aire así
es como los talibanes han terminado con
una manifestación de mujeres en kabul la
marcha fue frente al ministerio de
educación de afganistán y ellas
protestaban ante los numerosos derechos
perdidos en este año de control talibán
un poder que les ha arrebatado entre
otras cosas su derecho a la educación
haciendo que algunas de estas mujeres y
niñas tengan que educarse en la
clandestinidad no a madre sara me den mi
hermano es talibán y no me permitió
venir aquí incluso trató de detenerme
cuando estaba en octavo grado que
madrastra yo utilizo la excusa de venir
a la madrasa cuando en realidad vengo a
la escuela mi hermano no sabe que vengo
a la escuela y solo mi madre me apoya
tanto las estudiantes como sus
profesoras ponen su vida en peligro en
cada clase que asisten un riesgo que
están dispuestas a asumir a cambio de
tener una mínima oportunidad para
formarse detrás de esta educación
clandestina hay profesoras que ya
sufrieron la violencia talibán durante
el anterior gobierno entre 1996 y 2000
no mujeres que no quieren que estas
líneas sufran lo que ellas sufrieron
quiero que estas niñas sean como yo
deberían tener un futuro mejor que yo da
igual actualmente muchos de estos niños
menores de edad se ven obligadas a
casarse como me tocó hablar ambas me
comprometí a los 12 años he sufrido
mucho para obtener una educación es por
eso que no quiero que pasen por tanto
los talibanes terminaron con 20 años de
libertad para las mujeres el 15 de
agosto de 2021 luego de que tomaran
kabul tras una precipitada salida de
eeuu y sus aliados